turn to the
[Music]
come left girl work you better work girl
yeah better work here's our working
story look at the headline because they
don't remember
okay here it is cardi b launches only
fans account
for behind the scenes content and
glimpses into personal life she's
starting a patreon
yeah she's starting a patreon and uh
cardi b
is starting a porn page is that isn't
fans only for porn
i don't know it's not what is it you can
it's basically any type of photo that
you want and you just charge people
it's like a type of patreon but usually
it's meant for like
you know kind of saucy guys they move
their monkey guys move their monkey to
her for her fans only picture
this girl what girls yeah move their
monkey wow that's crazy so she's
starting a subscription page
yeah work work at cardi work [ __ ] you got
that wet ass
[ __ ] and that's it that's it
what is [ __ ] so she's our working girl
is it empowering for a guy to ask you if
you got that whop or only girls can ask
if you got that [ __ ]
um i don't think it's appropriate to
ever go up to someone and ask if they
have a whop
unless you are intimate with them why
though i mean it's like the song's about
to
notice isn't that weird to just go up to
the people to be like yo you got that
wob
that's harassment isn't it i don't know
i'm asking you because you know i'm
trying to get one no cardi b
says it yeah cardigan she's obviously
saying it to her partner
like she's not like i don't actually i
don't know to each their own but i'm
just
if someone asks me if i got a whop i'm
gonna deck them so
yeah right okay let's ask uh the the
fans can you please
in the comments on patreon let us know
if it's okay to ask
each other if they got that [ __ ] like one
of the rules like can i ask
we know that binky mike's got that loaf
but does he also got that wob
does that he doesn't have that water and
can we do ask [ __ ] can we put it make
it
wet as [ __ ] can we do a w-a-a-p wet
ass what is that wet ass
no what what ass [ __ ] is wap still
yeah what ass [ __ ] that's it that's it
chris you got that wipe i got that [ __ ]
yeah i got that [ __ ]
whop cause your farts sound like you got
that wow because i'm
a whop with a [ __ ] zhongzhan
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just the
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to patreon.com
where things get really wild